die fed definierung auf sf mit di so
swiss re rb
[Musik]
die welt wandelt sich auch jene der
winzer für manche schweizer weinbauern
steht die zukunft auf dem spiel
in genf wo da mir mehr nur gegen den rat
seines vaters ins geschäft einsteigen
will
er sagte mir ganz klar mach was anderes
wer das mit leidenschaft macht opfer
gleich sein ganzes leben dafür
[Musik]
im loro piana schon dem betrieb seinen
sohn brasil übergeben hat es ist genauso
haltung mit seinen kindern zu arbeiten
die mit seinen vater jetzt habe ich das
sagen aber sicher müssen wir wachsen
[Musik]
im tessin oder das riesige weingut
tamburini nach generationen der
männerherrschaft nun von dieser jungen
frau valentina geleitet wird
als frau hat man es in diesem metier
nicht leicht es ist nach wie vor eine
männerdomäne
[Musik]
in graubünden wo ihren grünen felder
gegen den willen ihrer kinder das bio
zertifikat anstrengt
schwachsinn
auf dem weg hoch zum weingut denke ich
mir immer wunderschön da war stark
gefährdet
und im wallis wo marion brasch mit aller
kraft eines der vorzeige güte führt
sie ist die seele des weinguts begonnen
[Musik]
die winzerinnen der berggipfel die einen
nachfolger sucht
für diese fünf winzerinnen und winzer
ist der jahresverlauf voller
ungewissheit vier jahreszeiten
[Musik]
ich mache die kleinen rebzeilen da unten
raus mit der maschine nicht geht in die
kleinen moschee zeile unter zweiter
termin muss noch gemacht werden
ja es da gut einen tag später später
piranha unterstützt basel bei einer der
anspruchsvollsten aufgaben im frühling
dem aus glauben die heranwachsenden
trauben werden in diesem kleinen betrieb
noch von hand freigelegt damit die sonne
rankommt erinnerst du dich 2016 war es
nass und kalt beim auslaufen ja so ist
es angenehmer ja sicher es ist jedes
jahr wieder ganz anders genau dieses
frühjahr ist es sehr warm und trocken
dann bekam die natur im märz viel wasser
und alle chance auf einen schlag vor
ohne krankheit ohne probleme
so ist es eine wahre freude aber hier
sind wir gegenüber den anderen reden mit
der blüte im rückstand
[Musik]
weinlese am 20 september okay aber nicht
auf dieser parzelle also später ja
es ist mai und es gibt bereits anzeichen
für einen besonderen jahresverlauf in
der ganzen schweiz
[Musik]
oben in beton ist marion ganz alleine
beim auslaufen
hier auf 900 metern über meer finden
sich kaum hilfskräfte
[Musik]
ich bin ich antworte auf ihr inserat ich
war bisher vor allem in der schweiz
tätig es würde mich interessieren in der
landwirtschaft zu arbeiten
ich habe ihr stelleninserat gesehen was
er arbeitet sagt er nicht ich schicke
ihnen meinen lebenslauf
das ist ein lebenslauf es ist sehr
schwierig leute zu finden die für den
üblichen lohn in der landwirtschaft
arbeiten aber für jemanden der in erster
linie geld verdienen will und nicht
unbedingt spaß an der arbeit hat wird es
an einem ort wie diesem sehr schwer
demnächst kommt ein junger mann weiss
sehen
ich bin dauernd auf der suche
in der zwischenzeit gibt marion ihren
enkeln biodynamischen unterricht welches
ist das schönste
[Musik]
wie viele hörner fühlen wir david weiß
nicht zwei oder vier ist das tor nein
nicht tun sondern kieselerde wofür ist
kieselerde vasilis kieselerde ist
gehärtetes licht sie ist vor langer zeit
unter dem boden gewachsen
sie wird fein zerkleinert und dann
fühlen wir die hörner damit und setzten
sie in die erde
diese hörner entwickeln ihre ganze kraft
im boden
sie fangen die kräfte aus dem allein und
speichern sie wenn man sie auf die
pflanzen sprit dann verbreitet sich
überall licht und wärme ein zaubertrank
was nach quacksalberei aussieht ist ein
bio dynamisches verfahren das heute als
wirksam geht und immer breitere
anwendung findet in ihren anfängen in
den 70er jahren galten mario und jackie
jedoch als große pioniere in einer
eigenen welt
bei den grünen feldes wird nicht
biodynamisch gearbeitet aber dafür
strebt ihren das bio zertifikat an wo
für präzise kriterien zur erfüllung sind
flüssige form halt ein bisserl
haftmittel das bisher lengerichs rechnet
die richtige dosierung entscheidet über
erfolg oder misserfolg für ihre in und
ihren sohn johannes geht es darum die
wachsenden trauben zu schützen ohne
chemische substanzen einzusetzen
ein pflanzenschutzmittel
alles bio gerecht zu behandeln und
blätter befall mit pilzen wie echte oder
falsche mehltau zu verhindern
das ist ihre aufgabe
[Musik]
in genf wird biodynamisch gearbeitet
tanja ist eingestiegen
nach frostschäden im jahr 2017 gilt es
nun die reben zu schützen
man hofft auf mildes wetter diese kommt
auf wie vorhergesagt
das wetter ist immer ein thema aber
vater und sohn haben auch zeit für
andere geschichten
ich war bei ehrismann eben die kamen ja
auf das segeln zu sprechen
er sagte mir er habe einen restposten
einen see fritzen verkauft etwa
highlight ich sagte ihm in genf sei die
welt hat schon klein lustig beim segeln
musste genauso mit dem wetter spielen
können und den besten kompromiss finden
wie in den reden man muss sich dauernd
hinterfragen und manchmal stur sein
manchmal geduldig du musst dir sagen ich
mache das beste aus dem was mir die
natur anbietet
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
da geraten wir doch ein bisschen rein
während der blüte wäre schon gut wenn es
keinen hagelschlag gebe hagel kommt in
den reben ohnehin nie zur richtigen zeit
jetzt sind die schösslinge sehr
verletzlich und da alles ist noch grün
es ist noch nichts verholzt das heißt
hagelkörner würden voll auf die blüten
die trauben und die blätter treffen aber
natürlich auch auf die stärke durch ein
starkes hagelgewitter im juni verlieren
wir schon mal die trauben und vermutlich
auch die folge ernte weil die rebstöcke
und damit die knospen des folgejahres
beschädigt werden
schließlich können wir auch die triebe
nicht mehr richtig kürzen dort hinten
blitzt es und dort es ist leicht rosa
ein ganz übles gewitter
[Musik]
das gewitter hat sich verzogen doch was
hat es angerichtet
spannung herrscht in den rebbergen der
schweiz
[Musik]
wir sind spät dran macht nichts europa
freut mich alles okay ja ich habe die
runde gemacht alles in ordnung
gestern hagelte es
ich rief ihn sofort an und sagte der
hage kommt ich hatte angst dass den
reden etwas passiert wer keine netze
hatte hat jetzt keine knospen mehr da
ist die ganze ernte der netze hatte sie
aber sagen wir mal etwas rustikal
befestigte der hat einiges verloren
deswegen bin bei tamburini ab diesem
jahr die reden komplett mit hagelnetzen
abgedeckt im märz haben wir 68 kilometer
netzen angebracht
es war langwierig und mühsam aber so
können wir wenigstens ruhig schlafen
das weingut tamburini mit seinen 70
hektaren leistet sich also quasi ein
sicherheitsnetz das wetter ist ein
unsicherheitsfaktor
aber man muss im leben alles positiv
sehen wenn etwas passiert sind wir nicht
dafür verantwortlich sondern wir finden
wege und mittel um das problem zu lösen
es ist wie im leben man muss für alles
mögliche eine lösung finden
auch für die zukunft jeden montagmorgen
trinke ich in den reben ganz allein eine
flasche wein diesmal teile ich sie mit
euch
aus einer frühlingslaune heraus
organisiert valentina ein fotoshooting
in den reben
sie scheut keine mittel um ihren wein
wie gebührend anzupreisen
man sieht hier den blütenstand der sich
entwickelt hat
in der nächsten phase wachsen die
knospen und dann werden sie mit dem
beginn der blüte aufbrechen
im tessin beginnt die blütezeit
normalerweise das aufbrechen solltest du
erklären aufbrechen heißt die kalludra
eine art haube öffnet sich und bildet
eine blüte aus sind zwitter blüten
ich habe einen sehr guten ökologen und
einem sehr guten agronomen der die
arbeiter anleitet meine aufgabe ist es
unseren betrieb in der schweiz und warum
nicht auch im ausland bekannt zu machen
das bild mit der holzkiste passt er
nicht weil der wii nicht in holzkisten
verkauft wird
ich finde die kommunikation sehr wichtig
das ist definitiv das schönste wenn du
einen guten wein herstellt und dem anbau
alles richtig machst dann ist es schade
wenn du den wein nicht verkaufen kannst
die tat um
[Musik]
pierre monnet schoss hat anderes
anzupreisen
die vierte definiert basels vater ist
vizepräsident der veranstaltenden winzer
bruderschaft heute trifft er sich mit
den einwohnern wwz das winzerfest bringt
einen monat lang großen rummel mit sich
es kommen viele leute nach würfel nicht
nur wegen der vorstellungen
ich reise nicht weniger als 25.000
menschen nach der wm ein glas wein zu
trinken um zu holen
es gibt sicher einige die sich für diese
veranstaltung die pro generation einmal
stattfindet nicht begeistern können und
sich sagen ich mache dann ferien weil
wirbel während der fed definierung nicht
auszuhalten ist
[Musik]
die fette regierung ist seit neuesten
teil des weltkulturerbes der unesco
damit können sie bei ihren freunden mit
einer ansichtskarte werbung machen
die vorstellungen am sonntag montag
dienstag und mittwoch finden
normalerweise morgens um 11 uhr statt am
donnerstag freitag und samstag in das
abendveranstaltungen ab 9 uhr
wir haben mehr eintrittskarten als 1999
es sind rund 400.000 und die müssen alle
weg ein gigantisches fest zu ehren von
akribischer arbeit wie sie sein sohn
brasil und dessen frau nadija nur wenige
kilometer entfernt leisten für die
helfer und die winzer zählt nur ein
spektakel und das spielt sich in den
reben ab manchmal ist es ein drama
[Musik]
die trauben sind völlig kaputt
das gewitter war sehr heftig zuerst sehr
trockenen reine hagelkörner dann hagelte
es fünf minuten lang dem boden bildete
sich eine richtige eisschicht schäden
sind doch erheblich aber wir müssen
positiv bleiben ist aber nicht einfach
das hätten wir dieses jahr wirklich
nicht gebraucht aber vielleicht ist
alles nicht so schlimm
wir können nur hoffen dass die überreste
richtig blühen werden
aber es tut schon weh
[Musik]
ja hallo damiano ich habe eine frage zur
meldung von hagelschäden
wir hatten gestern ein gewitter und die
schäden sind sehr unterschiedlich ich
werde online eine schadensmeldung machen
und möchte wissen ob sich in gewissen
gebieten die frage der
schadensbegutachtung gar nicht stellt an
bestimmten orten gab es weniger
schadensfälle an anderen liegen wir weit
über 30 so läuft es im weinbau 2017
frost und 2018 schon zweimal habe und es
ist noch nicht mal mitte des jahres
es ist nicht einfach so etwas
wegzustecken
ich bin alt für mich geht es aber dann
ja fängt erst an die arbeiten seit 17
jahren zusammen und jetzt übernimmt er
den betrieb und er hat zwei kleine max
[Musik]
hallo mein schatz naja
gut geschlafen komm zu papa
[Musik]
den rebbergen entlang zum anderen ende
der schweiz bei ihrem treffen sich die
kollegen aus der gegend ein virus
bedroht die reben die winzer hängen an
den lippen des weinbau fachmanns das
virus weiter verbreitet als verein wenn
er die reben ziehen
es ist nicht schlecht das ganze es geht
leichter wieso es gibt ein so verkündet
die chance die wachsenden immer groß
kurze nokia kein psychotische punkt da
muss unten aus sally platte vor der ice
besonderes als person wir das auch
zeigen dass ganz schön aber sie über
spezielle ich unheimlich um es wirklich
um die treiber unter chrome handys
entdeckt und zwar mit oberteil
gruppendritter ohne durch aber dort
hinein ufer und das hat mir ich weiß
nicht ob ich irgendwas mit dem meist
selber hängt weil das finde ich ein
speziell das ist genau um der
meisterrunde
genau
[Musik]
bist du dir die gelbe punkte und die
gelben fleck ceo habe man das entdeckt
und aber sowie sagen ich habe in 600 im
turm zeigt nicht den videos team aber
warum angezeigt
[Musik]
einen versteckten feind zu bekämpfen ist
eine schwierige aufgabe
das problem muss gelöst werden ohne
gegen das angestrebte bio zertifikat zu
verstoßen
[Musik]
in beton hat marion besuch diesmal sind
es aber nicht ihre enkel der neue
angestellte den mario ungeduldig
erwartet hat ist endlich da kaum ist
christian angekommen geht es an die
arbeit
hier lautet die devise
selbst ist der mann
christian
was ist das problem da ist was
ausgeschlagen worden ein zahn durch
einen stein nein es bewegt sich dauernd
[Musik]
es bewegt sich von der bolzen kommt
draußen
das muss zum zahnarzt
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie wir beginnen sollen
also du hast noch keine assemblage
gemacht oder richtig ich habe noch
nichts gemacht
schauen wir was da ist und was wir dazu
geben können
im frühling muss man an sonnigen tagen
manchmal in den keller steigen und sich
im jahrgang 2000 17 widmen also den wein
probieren und zubereiten filtrieren und
in die flaschen apfel präpariert da
steckt ein bisschen von allem drin war
auch absehbar
wer sicher war absehbar die nummer eins
mag ich ähnlich wie die nummer drei
richtig gar mäßig mit kraft und einer
tannin masse die ich sehr gut integriert
finde das hatte ich mir vorgenommen
tannine und doch seidig und sehr
verschmolzen wir diskutieren über zwei
drei varianten und probieren sie machen
neue tests und probieren wieder
letztlich haben wir zwei meinungen die
einander hoffentlich bestärken und die
gewissheit bringen dass wir klug
gemischt haben wie findest du den
dritten in der nase doch leicht
animalisch ja ich habe ganz wenig 40
beigegeben
das hätte ich aus angst vor kritik nicht
gewagt aber ja er ist leicht verdaulich
im mund etwas trocken zumindest in der
mitte sehr trockene gerbstoffe sogar
etwas rustikal im abgang aber sehr dicht
das ist genau der stil dieses weins ich
habe mir gedanken gemacht und bin auf
die idee gekommen dass wir die weinlese
etwas vorziehen könnten um etwas mehr
frucht zu bekommen es gebe eine noch
geschmeidigeren weine und wir würden die
alkohol struktur die im mund sehr potent
ist in den griff kriegen
während glück und am jahr über die
assemblage diskutieren sind vater und
sohn mona schon beim abfüllen
brazil mittlerweile herr über die
gesamte produktion hat alles unter dem
wachsamen auge seines vaters gelernt
[Musik]
hier wird verkapselt und hier haben wir
die etikettierung klappt alles mit der
etikettierung bisher schon
als sie ins alter kamen in dem man
taschengeld bekommt habe ich meinen zwei
söhnen eine rebfläche zugewiesen
um diese sich selbst kümmern mussten so
haben sie gelernt die reben zu schneiden
triebe zu entfernen auszurauben und so
weiter die ernte habe ich dann für sie
verkauft und ihnen die einnahmen aus
jahres taschengeld gegeben
genau das richtige für einen winzersohn
gewinde ich zuerst war es zwang in den
reben zu arbeiten
es war heiß meine freunde gegenstimmen
lustig war es nicht gerade aber man
bekommt freude daran im freien zu
arbeiten und die pflanzen zu pflegen und
zu optimalem wachstum zu führen
schritt für schritt wird einem das mit
ihm immer vertraut hat ich denke für
mich war das eine sehr prägende
erfahrung
[Musik]
im tessin hat valentina jetzt auch das
sagen
am tag der offenen weinkeller steht sie
hinter der theke und empfängt die kunden
des weinguts tamburin bitte sie können
gern mehr haben ich schenke immer wenig
ein
der bass für die tambo ist dieses jahr
die neuheit im hause tamburini meinten
sie den es ist ein merlot aber
eigentlich eine spätlese die namen hat
mein vater erfunden
klingt aber gut sie sind also die
tochter ja ich bin valentina zusammen
mit meinem cousin führe ich diese schöne
familientradition weiter
das ist der tango schritt eben der passo
der uns den rhythmus für die zukunft
gibt
ich übernehme dem betrieb meines vaters
es ist mir völlig klar dass es eine
große aufgabe ist ein so bekanntes
weingut zu führen was total libro
ich weiß nicht ob ich es schaffe wenn
ich dann mache ich halt etwas anderes
das schicksal wird wohl darüber
entscheiden
mia vita valentina ist sehr dynamisch
wir kommen sehr gut miteinander aus ich
habe natürlich meine eigene arbeitsweise
bin speditiv und bringe alles auf den
punkt
valentina hingegen hat eine farbige
sprache und muss alles ausmalen
da gibt es manchmal schon auch
spannungen aber diese spannungen sind im
grunde eigentlich positiv und
vorübergehend einmal mehr bleibt claudio
im hintergrund man findet ihn in den
reben bei seinem chef ökonomen zu uns
kam ging ich samstags und sonntags durch
die reden und notierte mir alle mängel
hier ist aber ich stift und notizbuch
weggeworfen weil er ein wahrer profi ist
und sich um alles kümmert es ist nicht
mehr nötig dass ich kontrollgänge machen
ich kann mich also stolz dem verkauf der
legende tamburini widmen was für mich
wie ein lohn für die ganze arbeit ist
die ich über die jahre geleistet habe
[Musik]
in bildung oberhalb von vieh hält mario
die legende ganz alleine am laufen seit
der man ag im juni 2016 gestorben ist
[Musik]
unten holt sie ihren besuch ab einen
önologen und alten freund nikola der
papst fährt im papamobil herum und du
immerhin in dieser seilbahn
[Musik]
ich habe was zu trinken dabei nichts zu
essen
nein aber wie im restaurant war
[Musik]
sollte
irgendwie
[Musik]
ich frage mich wann ich zuletzt hier war
wie bitte ich frage mich wann ich
zuletzt hier war es war herbst
vermutlich zur saffran töte shutter und
du hast schöne fotos gemacht
das erste mal war ich mit winzern hier
michelle krise heraus erneuern und
manieren der übrigens in der selber
nicht schlecht staunte jackie erklärte
unten die weißen würden oben gepresst
und dann durch die kleinen schläuche
hier oben nach unten gespült ich kann
mich noch genau erinnern
louis mania sah das und sagte die
spinnen echte die anfänge von
unglaublich schon gesehen das ist
übrigens der hochzeitsanzug seines
vaters seine ausrede war aber die sind
jetzt total in mode
ich sagte fehrs glaubt als wären sie aus
einer englischen fernsehserie
unglaubliche bilder von chucky meinst du
als während des spiels kaum zu glauben
dass er selber ist wo habt ihr euch
kennengelernt
natürlich ein beton unfassbar
dort unten werden sie langsam fertig und
dort der pfeile an dem tag seinen unfall
hatte siehst du mich schief er ist über
das zug kabel gestolpert
[Musik]
es war warm und er stand auf los sehr
feiner erde
es war steil und zurück auf den weg
noch steiler der raupenschlepper ich
weiß nicht wie ich es sagen soll war in
der erde festgefahren und kippte zur
seite
aber wie die arbeiter waren nicht weit
entfernt beim elektrizitätswerk
vielleicht 100 oder 200 meter sie sahen
nur wie das gerät kippte die sicht war
durch blätter verstellt niemand weiß was
genau geschah
[Musik]
doch woran und er hätte auch anderswo
einen unfall haben können
ich weiß dass er sehr glücklich war er
hatte beim essen mit den anderen allen
ein freundliches wort gesagt
er war sehr zufrieden einer frau die von
der arbeit nach hause ging hat er von
seinem pferd aus noch zugewinkt er war
zufrieden mit den arbeitern
es war ein schöner tag er liebte seine
arbeit und war in form
er ist glücklich gegangen
auch im tessin wird heute der familie
gedacht valentina organisiert einen
wohltätigkeits abend für ihre
verstorbene jüngere schwester ich wollte
immer eine wohltätigkeitsveranstaltung
machen sucht aber noch den passenden
verein diesmal ist claudio dabei eine
seltenheit
mein vater kommt
claudio tamburini claudia dorn der
vereins-präsident guten abend carlo
hallo wie geht's schön freut mich sehr
dass du kommst leicht verspätet kein
problem
willkommen zu dieser besonderen
veranstaltung
es freut mich sehr dass carlo ranbaxy
hier ist der pate meines weines wie
für mich ist es sehr wichtig den verein
für seltene krankheiten zu unterstützen
dies im gedenken an eine person die mir
sehr nahe stand nämlich meine schwester
ali t die uns leider viel zu früh
verlassen hat wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass das leben kurz ist und wir mehr
lachen sollten jedem wein seine
geschichte der wifi ist im grunde meiner
schwester gewidmet ich finde dass viele
menschen vielleicht sogar die jungen zu
wenig lachen und zu negativ sind die
wohnkultur jesus meine schwester trug
immer ein lachen auf den lippen selbst
in der chemotherapie und sie war erst
sechs jahre alt
es ist auch eine botschaft an die welt
lebe jeden moment mit freude carpe diem
genießt das leben
wieso auch nur eine einzige minute
dieses lebens im streit verschwinden
oder mit traurig sein
natürlich darf man in schwierigen
momenten traurig sein aber dann muss man
sich wieder fangen sich sammeln und sich
auf die hoffnungsschimmer konzentrieren
sich daran hochziehen und nach vorne
schauen
natürlich ist es nicht einfach ins auto
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein gewitter mit 15 oder 20 millimetern
regen ist keine katastrophe das kommt
oft vor aber der pflanzenschutz ist ein
am boden
das heißt dass der kupfer und schwefel
eintrag ausgewaschen wurden deshalb muss
vor dem nächsten gewitter unbedingt
gehandelt werden
[Musik]
es ist ein kompliziertes jahr im
konventionellen anbau wäre es vielleicht
der richtige moment einen mittel
einzusetzen dass systemische wirkt und
in die pflanzen eindringt und sie von
innen schützt ein mittel das nicht so
leicht ausgewaschen wird und mehr
regenmengen aushält ich habe mir das
überlegt aber ich ziehe es vor dieses
jahr mit einfachen kontakt produkten 20
prozent mehr zu behandeln als im
konventionellen anbau
wir werden es nicht übertreiben ich
denke wir haben immer noch spielraum um
im rahmen der anforderungen zu bleiben
[Musik]
daniel schöpft wieder hoffnung
er nimmt eine auszeit um sich von den
strapazen zu erholen
auf dem segelboot lässt du sämtliche
alltagsprobleme zurück du legst ab
längst das boot beobachtet die segel
fachsimpelt diskutierst über die
wasserfläche und vergisst alle sorgen
[Musik]
an der ball doch der vorzeige regatta am
genfer see sind auch winzer an bord
an der kreuzung der sich auch frei
genommen hat
[Musik]
weitab vom see kämpft marion mit anderen
wasser phänomenen
[Musik]
diese leitungen versorgen das ganze
weingut direkt ab quelle ist eine
verstopft muss jemand so schnell wie
möglich den berg hoch der sommer naht im
eiltempo
[Musik]
einfach alles daran warum ihm die tasche
ohne wasser kein beton gibt es ein
problem kann ich nicht einfach die
wasserwerke anrufen und sagen
bringen sie das bitte sofort in ordnung
immer wenn eine leitung verstopft ist
muss sie gereinigt werden
[Musik]
bloß nicht runter schauen
im sommer muss in bildung unter anderem
die quelle gesäubert werden
das problem ist alles muss geleert
werden in der ganzen schweiz sind die
reben diesen sommer außergewöhnlich
hohen temperaturen ausgesetzt virus
besiegen und bio zertifikat in jenins
erst gewitter dann trockenheit in genf
frühling trocken sommeranfang trocken
kein regen in sicht
überall in den schweizer reden ist ein
neues jahr zu meistern
[Musik]
die fed definierung auf sf mit die swiss
und legria